okay the best way to go about learning
all of this is to make a picture so
we'll work with a device you've seen
before the inside of a music box will be
looking at getting the right exposure
that is capturing the right amount of
light from your device or sample onto
your camera setting with your 105 lens
so let's do this stepwise I've
previously installed the software
specific to my camera so I'll open it up
I keep my dock on the left I'll click on
it and lo and behold I get a message
that no camera is detected okay so now
what I'm afraid I do this a little too
often something I want to alert you to I
met I forget yes I think it's a good
idea to turn your camera on and for all
this to work so I'll do that turn the
camera on and so here we go our software
opens up and we see the screen which
finally gives me the way to set exposure
settings to adjust the shutter speed and
aperture setting but first we're going
to go to another screen at least in this
software giving me the ability to set
the ISO number I'll set it to the lowest
possible number the camera offers so
that we get the finest picture possible
and that's what we'll do here we'll set
it at 200 now that number tells the
sensor how sensitive it should be while
letting in the light from your material
the higher you set the ISO number for
example 6400 the more sensitive you make
your sensor in low-light conditions that
could be the way to go but remember we
have control over our setup and in
principle should be able to add as much
light as we need but there's a problem
when you set your ISO number hi the
sensor becomes so sensitive that it
picks up noise electronic signals from
the circuitry in your camera
the noise appears as graininess it's not
digital information from your subject
and it's not what we want take a look at
the difference between these two images
one is set at 200 ISO pretty low number
compared to the other set at 6,400 the
graininess in the 6400 ISO image is not
what we want by the way I hope you're
viewing these images on a computer or a
tablet I'm not sure you'll be able to
pick up the differences on a phone it's
really significant in this software we
have to go back to the first screen to
set the aperture which will do now we're
going to set it at f 32 for our purposes
we want as much as possible in focus
notice down here that we cf32 indicated
as well ok now we set the shutter speed
which we decide while looking at the
exposure readout we're aiming for the
readout to indicate zeros smack in the
middle notice it here in the readout not
underexposed nor overexposed the
exposure readout is in fact very similar
to what you would see in your viewfinder
just easier to see in my opinion and
here's where the tripod comes in you
might have to set the shutter speed at
maybe a half a second for example now I
don't know about you but if I hand held
the camera in that very slow shutter
speed the image would just not be sharp
when I blow it up see these two images
one while i partially handheld leaning
the camera on the tripod and the other
with the cameras securely mounted on the
tripod quite a difference you'll have
the luxury of shooting at slow shutter
speeds without the worry of a quivering
camera if you use a tripod
okay so i have set the is oh the
aperture and shutter speed and we will
now click on live view which is another
great thing about the software we can
see two things first we see if we have
to make adjustments in composition to
see if it's straight perhaps we also see
the image with the aperture setting
we've set we see what is in focus okay
we're ready to take the picture and we
click on shoot the image is immediately
captured on the camera and now watch
while the image immediately downloads
onto the computer pretty fast much
faster these days and it used to
download and here to even with this
small thumbnail you can see if the
exposure is pretty much on target and if
your composition is right again if the
image seems crooked you can go back and
forth and fix it in Live View to make it
work so let's review the reasons why you
should consider using software to adjust
your exposure setting first you can
easily see your exposure settings second
you can immediately see if your settings
are right third you can adjust your
composition in real time in Live View
and that view is the aperture you've set
showing you what is and what is not in
focus and forth you can store the image
directly onto your computer without
worrying about storage room on a camera
card but again if you choose not to use
the software all your exposure settings
can be made in your camera just read
your manual